Nacéra si tu pouvais changer quelque
chose à ton visage par exemple qu'est-ce
que tu changerais
s'il te plaît pas
ça me fait pas d'avoir sonné alors je me
suis dit que si j'avais de l'argent que
je gagnerai peut-être au loto ça peut
toujours arriver et ben je me ferai
changer le nez
on peut changer son aide la chirurgie
esthétique j'ai le nez de ma mère et là
ça fait comme ça et puis là c'est
ma grand-mère elle me dit que ma
grand-mère elle me dit qu'est-ce que tu
t'es fait tu t'écrases pas
enfin je me dis des fois que quand je
vais à Marseille ou quoi je vois les
gens je regarde déjà comme ça oh là là
ça me fait la peine parce que vraiment
leur nez il est vraiment exagéré
[Applaudissements]
ça me plaît pas le mien si je pouvais je
me l'enlèverai Sophie
sauf si tu pouvais changer quelque chose
toi qu'est-ce que tu changerais
rien tu te plaît bien comme ça
au moins je resterai solitaire
que peut-on faire pour maigrir pour
perdre un peu de poids
ou alors des légumes bouillis voilà
surtout des nouveaux arrivés
tu penses que ta famille sera surprise
c'est une fois tu changes ton nez ils
auront l'impression d'avoir la même
petite fille à la maison
[Musique]